liliana tiene un negocio de decoración
de pasteles el 10% de su trabajo son
pedidos por teléfono se hace el número
de pedidos que viviana recibe en un mes
hasta que tiene el primer pedido por
teléfono supone que haya independencia
entre los distintos métodos para hacer
un pedido si suponemos algunas cosas
podemos decir que se es una variable
aleatoria geométrica clásica el
indicador de que es una variable
geométrica es que vamos a seguir
realizando ejecuciones independientes
donde la probabilidad de éxito es
constante en este caso el éxito es un
pedido por teléfono y la probabilidad de
que esto ocurra es del 10%
vamos a realizar ejecuciones hasta que
tengamos un éxito es una variable
aleatoria geométrica clásica nos
preguntan la probabilidad de que la
cantidad de pedidos sea menor a 5 antes
de que liliana tenga su primer pedido
telefónico en el mes es la probabilidad
de que se sea menor a 5 como siempre
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolver
esto por su cuenta aún cuando les cueste
un poco de trabajo resolverlo
su cerebro estará mejor preparado para
cuando resolvamos esto juntos supongo
que lo intentaron vamos a resolverlo hay
dos maneras de abordar esto podríamos
considerar que es igual a la
probabilidad de que se sea igual a 1 más
la probabilidad de que se sea igual a 2
más la probabilidad de que se sea igual
a 3 más la probabilidad de que se sea
igual a 4 vamos a calcular lo primero de
esta manera cuál es la probabilidad de
que se sea igual a 1 es la probabilidad
de que su primer pedido sea por teléfono
lo cual es 0.1 cuál es la probabilidad
de que sea igual a 2 es la probabilidad
de que el primer pedido no haya sido por
teléfono aún no le restamos 0.1 lo que
nos da 0.9 y el segundo pedido sea por
teléfono que es 0.1 en este caso los
primeros dos pedidos no fueron por
teléfono y el tercer pedido es
telefónico y para ser igual a 4 los tres
primeros pedidos no fueron por teléfono
y el cuarto pedido es telefónico podemos
usar una calcular
para sumar todo esto y tener el
resultado que buscamos pero quizá
piensen que es bastante laborioso
escribir todo esto en la calculadora y
haya una forma más sencilla de resolver
esto y en efecto la hay
piensen que la probabilidad de que se
sea menor a 5 es igual a 1 menos la
probabilidad de que no tengamos un
pedido telefónico en las cuatro primeras
ejecuciones lo escribimos no a pedidos
telefónicos en las primeras cuatro
ejecuciones
lo que escribimos aquí arriba es la
probabilidad de que tengamos un pedido
telefónico en alguna de las primeras 4
ejecuciones y lo que escribimos aquí
abajo es lo mismo
1 - la probabilidad de no tener un
pedido telefónico en las primeras cuatro
ejecuciones esta última forma es
bastante sencilla de calcular usemos
otro color para que sea más fácil de
visualizar la probabilidad de no tener
un pedido telefónico es 0.9 y eso tiene
que ocurrir cuatro veces es 0.9 a la
cuarta potencia esto es mucho más
sencillo de calcular
usemos nuestra calculadora ponemos 0.9 a
la cuarta potencia y esto vamos a
restarlo de 1 nos queda 0.3 mil 439 lo
escribimos
esta es la probabilidad de tener un
pedido telefónico en menos de 5
ejecuciones y con esto terminamos